i believe for fact that some of the most  special people that walk earth their  parents and the school system have  sucked their specialty out and they will  be a shell of themselves and they will  not create the things that change our  earth because of modern povs on hyper  kids if i was unlucky and was born 40  years later to a different mother i can  tell you right now i would have not  achieved who i was because they would  have had me on everything i was  completely out of control and that out  of controlness allowed me to see the  world differently allowed me to innovate  allowed me to be more thoughtful allowed  me to be clear  in the gray